foreign
[Music]
hello everybody Welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
Ryan Nicodemus is at Burning Man this
week but don't worry he'll be back on
the next episode we've got some special
guests for you today on this free public
minimal episode we're also here with
malabama hi T.K Coleman is in the studio
what it is we got the rest of our team
here and today we're going to be talking
to Vanessa Bennett and John Kim authors
of this book it's not me it's you and
we're talking to a listener about
relationship clutter we also have an
outstanding lightning round question
listener tip and added value segment for
you you can check out the full two hour
maximal edition of episode 358 where we
answer four times the questions and dive
deep into seven simple living segments
that private podcast episode is out
right now at patreon.com
Flash the minimalists your support keeps
our podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck Mal where are we
starting today let's start with a
question from Caitlin in Arkansas
hi my name is Caitlin and I'm a patreon
subscriber from Fayetteville Arkansas
I'm in my mid-20s and I've never been in
a serious relationship after spending
years focused on building my career I'm
in a stable job and I've done a lot of
inner work on myself
how do I intentionally pursue finding a
life partner without clinging to that
Pursuit I want to start a relationship
from a place of intentionality and
health not out of desperation or
loneliness
what a thoughtful question yeah right
for somebody in their mid-20s like no
offense but that that says something
about Caitlyn
you want to go first yeah uh I would say
um to build a life so
I I I heard this when I was going
through my rebirth and I've always kept
it in my back pocket
um where are you going and then who's
going with you if you reverse the order
you'll be going alone and say that
because I spent most of my 20s and 30s
trying to find out who's going to come
with me before where am I going so I put
the relationship or the person above
um my true north or my passion or what I
wanted to do and so what happens is uh
then there's this um this the stickiness
and that Dynamic where
um you're putting people on pedestals
you're hanging your happiness or life on
the relationship and and uh also you you
go from uh in my case I went from mouth
to nipple I went from
um you know someone who uh was building
something and then found love and then
lost myself and the dynamic of the
relationship changed where I was more
like her son than her partner so
Vanessa I find it what's interesting
here and I think you allude to this in
the book but needing a relationship
becomes a type of relationship clutter
in a way and I think what John is saying
here is if we're heading in One
Direction and then someone else we meet
they drag us in a separate Direction
when we talk about clutter as the
minimalists we're really talking about
things that get in the way right now
obviously there's material clutter and
we talk a lot about that but once you
get past the stuff there's all of this
other clutter mental clutter emotional
clutter spiritual clutter and of course
relationship clutter and I think part of
that clutter is thinking we need someone
a particular person or or a type of
person to complete me and as you talk
about the book that's a bit of a myth
yeah I mean I think actually I've never
heard you say what you just said John
and I love that I'm probably gonna steal
that you even know me for later
I'm like oh noted
um but yeah I mean I think what you said
is spot on I think it goes back to what
you're saying you know just it's like if
we are worried about building ourselves
and we're focusing on our passion what
lights us up what what kind of gets us
up in the morning right and drives us
then what's probably going to happen is
you're going to draw people into your
sphere that complement you and that
illuminate you in a way that it's going
to be the opposite if what like John's
saying you're worried about the people
first and then yourself and your passion
second right and so I do believe there
is a clutter to the neediness that we
have around relationships now all that
to say I don't want to place blame on
people because that's a societal thing
right that clutter comes to us through
messaging that we get from society that
we are not complete unless we are
partnered right that we are not complete
until we have the big house and the
fancy car I mean you all know this well
it's what you guys talk about and so I
think it's really important and I do
think there has been a shift as of late
where we do start to turn it on its head
and kind of go at it like you said John
which is like me and spirit first and
then allowing the rest to come in as a
way to kind of just be an added bonus
but not be it now that's not don't
people think that is selfish though oh
but I should of course be subservient I
should follow their needs of course but
then what happens if we do that we're
codependent is all hell right I mean
that's what that is like and again
societally I mean we we live in a
codependent Society we are taught that
relationships and love look feel sound
smell like codependency you lose
yourself in each other you're complete
when you meet somebody else right you
were incomplete when you were on your
own so if we really want to start
breaking these codependent patterns that
we've got as a society it's not that
it's selfish as a matter of fact it's
the opposite I think it's more selfish
to go into a relationship when I don't
really know who I am or have my own
passions and expect the other person to
complete me and make me happy than
actually coming in knowing what makes me
happy and then knowing that this person
is just a charity on the Sunday that
feels a hell of a lot less selfish to me
by the way there's a reason why Vanessa
is called Dakota Yoda on Tick Tock okay
can you tell us the your definition of
codependency because I love it
I'm sorry sorry let me give the Baton
back to you yeah I mean like for those
who are listening yeah I mean it's one
of the big things I talk about but it's
it seems more complicated than it is
right so the way I break it down is just
simply this if you're good I'm good if
you're not good I'm not good that in and
of itself is codependency right my
emotional self is based outside of
myself my sense of worth is found
outside of myself myself my emotional
state is based on somebody else's
emotional state and that is literally
the country that we live in I mean
that's how we look at love for many of
us that's how we've learned to do
friendship yep that's all relationships
that's literally how some people would
Define being empathetic yes when you're
down I'm going to be a good friend and
be down with you or else I overwhelm you
with my joy so how do you yeah how do
you maintain your own Joy when someone
you love is right there next to you in a
dark State without without making them
feel like you don't care yeah when you
said that like overwhelm you with my joy
they just like hit me right in the heart
also as a man locker rooms it's like if
you're my boy
you go down coming down with you there's
like this weird kind of loyalty to it
that is uh romanticized um but I don't
think it's healthy for me it's like I'll
give you my hand not my life right so if
you're going through a depression
um of course I care about you I want to
know how I can support you but I'm not
also gonna go through the depression as
well because you're going through a
depression you know what I'm saying yeah
yeah so like a practical situation let's
say
um you show up at work or you show up at
home and you say to a friend hey how's
it going and they tell you my day is
horrible and they've gone right and then
they say how about you and the truth is
that you just won the lottery
but you don't want to be like well yeah
I'm doing fantastic I'm a millionaire
now yeah what do you do in those kinds
of moments I think there's a way for you
to empathize and then but not rub it in
their face I think there's a difference
between still maintaining your own joy
and not feeling bad about the fact that
you're in a good place and rubbing it in
someone's faces right there's a line
there so in that practical example it
might be maybe I don't In This Moment
talk about the fact that I just want the
lottery right I can still talk about
that maybe later but maybe right now it
just becomes while I'm really sorry to
hear that I'm sorry that you're going
through such a hard time
but also you can say you're doing well
because that you are doing well yeah you
shouldn't have to hide that right right
you don't have to say I just won 800
million dollars but um I'm having a good
day and that's my truth man you know
yeah
now in the book uh the subtitle is break
the blame cycle and quite often
when I talk about the blame being
immature I mean it's the The Telltale
sign of immaturity because it's a
narcissistic trait as well whenever I am
blaming everyone else for my problems my
offense my desires my inadequacies and
vocal quotes there
all right what I'm doing is I'm
abdicating My Own responsibility I'm
abdicating My Own control the very few
things that I have control over I'm now
lending out to everyone else and I'm
blaming TK in a weird way I'm giving him
the power to offend me to make me upset
right it doesn't mean that TK should be
a jerk all the time because yeah I don't
I can't be offended by him no of course
um he can he can treat me kindly But
ultimately it is up to me to determine
yeah who I ultimately I'm the one to
blame and I think I'm starting to
understand that through through reading
the book what you're talking about here
is is a type of personal responsibility
yeah I mean a lot of this for me anyway
going through Al-Anon a lot of this is
very simple 12-step stuff right it's
like what is your 100 keeping your side
of the street clean in every you know
TKA we're talking a little bit offline
before we started recording that
sometimes I this isn't gonna this
doesn't go over well with many but even
as a as a couples therapist I've had
people come in for like let's say
infidelity and one of the first things I
I ask I mean after some reporters bill
and I don't do it in an attacking way
but a lot of times I will turn to the
person who's been cheated on and ask
them what was your role in this what was
your part in this and let me tell you
they don't like that they don't like it
and I understand where that comes from
right I get that I've been victimized
but staying in the victimhood space for
too long is another way we give our
power away right and by the way there's
always two people in every Dynamic and
so no you might directly have caused the
cheating that's not what I'm saying but
sometimes I'll hear
um you know when somebody's at the place
where they can own it they might say
something like
um well I noticed that things have
shifted and I never said anything
I didn't speak up the last six months
he's felt very distant or she's felt
very distant or wasn't coming home and I
just didn't say anything I just got
resentful okay well that's your part to
own right again I'm not saying you
directly caused the cheating but when we
get to a place where we can own our 100
that's when the real conversation start
until then it's just the blame game I'm
the victim you're the perpetrator and
that keeps us in a really unhealthy
pattern which by the way is really hard
to do but that's a nice struggle with it
as well
um ownership is difficult you know
especially if that's not the pattern
it's why it's one of the 12 stops right
it's it's its own thing it's tough I
remember several years ago Oprah
popularized the DVD The Secret yeah and
I do not want to get into the
metaphysics of the law of attraction at
all but there was a phrase that came out
of that that became really popular and
it was you create your own reality yes
and a lot of people started saying that
I create my own reality I create my own
reality and there was a lot of backlash
against that statement because as
it it sounded to some as a very
privileged sort of statement right there
are people in this world that are deeply
traumatized they've had really terrible
things happen to them and they're there
asking well okay I created my own
reality someone attacked me someone
heard it hurt me I created that what
would you what would you say is the
balance between self-ownership or
personal responsibility and being honest
about the bad things that happened to us
that we didn't seem to invite it's a
really good question today you want to
do that you want to take it
um I think when we're talking about the
relationship and conflict in the
relationship
um
you do in a sense create your reality
from the day you choose to love someone
and then as you get to know them because
you know love is a daily choice you
don't have to be in something if you
don't want to if it doesn't work for you
right so
um there is a responsibility
and not blaming in that but when it
comes to people's story like trauma
that is uh uh
we have been
um victims like whether you know there
was sexual abuse or you know bullying or
all the stuff that happens to us because
you know no child enters adulthood
unscarred all of that
um I think is different than when you're
in a relationship and you want to take
ownership of
um how you love someone or what you
bring to the table part of taking
ownership is actually looking at your
story how you were wired and following
that string down and realizing why you
behave and act the way that you do I
want to build on that though and just
say that even in those situations
because I know exactly what you're
saying the privilege around like I
didn't create this reality right no one
is saying that you are too blame for the
traumatic things that happen in your
life by all means absolutely not no one
is saying that and what that statement
is saying is that if that has been your
reality what will you do with it now
right so there still is a choice even in
the most victimized to say I'm going to
stay in that place now look we could get
into the whole like Mental Health
Services are they offered to people in
different areas and different income
brackets all that we could I mean that
is valid and fair and it's about saying
this has been my life up to this point
this is the a deck of cards I've been
dealt what will I do with this hand
right and that I believe rather than
look at it as victim blaming that's
actually giving you power back and if we
look at it like I'm Gonna Take Back
Control and play this hand that feels a
lot different than like I'm to blame for
the reality that's happened to me does
that make sense that makes a lot of
sense personal responsibility is not the
same thing as self-blame yes
that's it let me steal that from being
right there
oh it's your name it'll be TKO now which
is a quote uh Caitlin I'm gonna send you
a copy of this book it's not me it's you
by John Kim and Vanessa Bennett I think
you will enjoy that book and you'll find
some value in it as you are making this
exploration malabama what time is it and
you know what time it is it's time for
the lightning round yes indeed you can
text your questions and comments to
937-202-4654 we answer them throughout
the week via our phones but we answer
some some here on the podcast now during
the lightning round here's what we do we
and our guests we try to answer
questions with a short shareable less
than 140 character response but not
really you can ramble a little bit I was
like Professor Sean gives you 60 seconds
on the clock and you can answer this
question within 60 seconds and we try to
tweeze out something pithy we call them
minimal maxims and uh podcast John puts
them in the show notes so people can
share our pithy answers on social media
if they like it looks like Casey has a
question for us I have absolutely found
my person but we're not sure if we want
to get legally married what are the pros
and cons of legal marriage let's put 60
seconds on the clock for TK Coleman what
do you got for us TK something
completely unprep but let's do it
contracts are for lawyers creativity is
for Lovers uh I quote The Economist
Thomas solo who said There Are No
Solutions there are only trade-offs and
how do you determine what trade-offs are
right for you you look within at your
own preferences your own principles your
own priorities I call those the three
p's and they will take you everywhere
you need to go you can't make good
decisions in life by academically
writing down the pros and cons on a
sheet of paper because those pros and
cons have to be contextualized by what
matters most to you and that has to come
from within what are your preferences
what are your principles what are your
priorities that'll let you know the
trade-offs that you need to make we've
got 60 seconds on the clock for he's
going with your answer can I just say
everything
uh we put too much weight on the promise
why do you want to get married why is
that valuable to you
I would say hold this instead of a grab
it and ask yourself what holding it
looks like like feeding Birds if you are
uh holding meaning with an open hand and
let the bird come to you that's gonna
build legs of a relationship if you're
chasing after the bird to feed it you're
going to chase it away so if you're
using marriage to chase instead of hold
on I think it's a good thing and what I
like about your answer here is you're
not saying marriage is good or bad but
it is not always the goal my wife and I
aren't married on paper but I refer to
as my wife because culturally people
understand that right right in fact we
live apart half the time as well which
is also a weird cultural thing people
like oh my God we were having dinner
with someone one time I'm still using
his 60 seconds here and I say oh yeah we
live apart half time and someone said no
don't do that
what are you talking about no I do do
that I'm going to do that because I've
realized the distance is what creates
the desire in our ah I got the buzzer
all right we got 60 seconds on the clock
for Vanessa Bennett God I don't have
anything pithy to say after these two I
feel like they said it all but uh as
somebody who myself similar not married
but live together have a child own a
home all the things I mean the perks are
probably tax cuts I guess but again
what's your should and why is there a
should and where does this should come
from right like who is telling you that
this is what your life should look like
and then you need to question that this
is a radical departure from what we've
been told I think generationally we're
finally breaking out of we have to do
things a certain way and so I think
marriage is just one of those having
children is another one of those
um ask yourself where that shirt is
coming from is it coming from you or is
it coming from external and you and your
partner just need to be kind of on the
same page about it yes indeed there are
no shoulds there are only could and as
soon as we realize that it opens up all
of the possibility is you want to put 60
seconds up there for me it says TK stole
my pithy answer and reworded it I
actually stole this one and reworded
something from our friend Seth Godin so
contracts inform us about the past
handshakes inform us about the future so
my wife and I don't have a specific
contract with respect to our marriage
but if you look at famous marriages from
the past there are plenty of people who
have been together you know and weren't
married by the state because it's not
about well as soon as I have this
contract the contract says oh I've been
screwed over in the past and I don't
want you to screw me over again and so
we're going to sign this contract TK and
what's fascinating is I don't have
contracts with anyone we work with here
right in fact Matt diovella who directed
our first two films I don't have a
contract with him we had a handshake
agreement every time that's amazing and
the reason and if in fact even we worked
with Netflix they sent me this like 80
page contract I said can you get this on
two pages and they're like what no one's
ever after his head's exploded yeah yeah
and I said well I don't want to sign
something I don't understand let's have
a handshake so we can work together
going forward that's 60 seconds
true Alpha he was like not only did you
steal my
tweet I'm gonna take it back slam dunk
it before the shot clock so Alabama what
else you got for us before we get to our
simple living segments and also we're
going to do another home tour segment
coming up what do you got for us in the
meantime here's a minimalist Insight
from one of our listeners
hi guys my name is Maria I'm from Moscow
Russia uh I have a bipolar disorder and
most of the time I don't have a lot of
energy so stuff kind of piles up
um whenever I do have it I start
decluttering and I don't just get rid of
things I don't need or like or haven't
used in a while I also ask myself does
this thing makes me feel better about
myself or worse for example I'm good at
cooking and since I have to eat I cook
once a week or so but mostly I live on
takeouts and orderings and even though I
always order healthy food and have a
pretty good eating habits I still feel
guilty about not having home-cooked
meals I never wanted to cook in the
first place but having all those cooking
stuff and not using it puts stress on me
it's uh three times a day struggle
so last month I said to myself okay I
don't want to worry about that anymore
it makes me like myself less so I got
rid of most of my kitchenware and kept
only a few things essential to making
eggs and coffee I instantly felt better
without all those pants and pots
starring at me every time I enter my
kitchen I don't have that stress anymore
and while I don't recommend that
particular kind of cleanup I will
definitely say to anyone with bipolar or
depression that having only things that
you like to use or just look at will
make you feel so much better I know that
most of us think one day I'll get better
and I finish that book or DIY project
but sometimes not doing that is what
makes you closer to getting better so
throw it out find it in your home
you don't want stuff dragging you down
all right y'all before we get to our
added value segment this week big thanks
to Our Guest today John Kim Vanessa
Bennett here's their new book if you're
watching the video version here it's not
me it's you it's a book about breaking
the blame cycle and relation shipping
better I love relationship as a verb you
can also check out their individual
podcasts the angry therapist podcast and
cheaper than therapy we'll put a link to
both of those in the show notes real
quick TK for right here right now here's
one thing that's going on in the life of
the minimalist we just had our first
ever Sunday Symposium it was magical
Yaman was there our whole team was there
Ryan was on stage with us as well we had
a beautiful special guest Amanda Montel
was there and we're doing our next one
when this podcast comes out it'll be
next week so less than a week away and
here's why I'm saying this last time we
announced this on the podcast the event
sold out in less than a day and so we're
announcing this right now you can head
on over to the minimalists.com tour you
can find tickets to the Sunday Symposium
now here's what we're doing this theater
that we have Dynasty typewriter
beautiful theater
it's only 200 seats we did this
intentionally smallest event we've done
in like seven or eight years TK yeah and
that intimacy creates something special
we learned a lot from the first one
we're going to be doing a lot of
different things with the second one
we're trying to build a loving
dogma-free Community people who come
back over and over and new people who
join the community in ebb in and out of
our community 100 free tickets available
100 paid tickets available if you can
afford it please donate for a ticket you
buy a ticket it's a donation and that
helps us pay for the venue helps us pay
for our staff but it also subsidizes the
people who cannot afford a ticket we
want this to be open to everyone no
matter where you are on the
socioeconomic Spectrum this is happening
right now monthly in Los Angeles what'd
you learn from that first event TK
man that
everywhere you go man everywhere you go
people want to connect one of the
interesting observations for me was how
many people who were there that grew up
in church grew up in religious
communities and they still retain a
sense of maybe moral values or spiritual
values that they inherited from those
religious communities but they're no
longer a part of those communities
themselves and no longer desire to be a
part of them but they miss the part
where you gather together with other
people to talk about a common aspiration
to live more intentional lives and
that's why we called it Sunday Symposium
in fact you were a bit worried like oh
no I don't want the connotation we're
doing this noon I didn't like it at all
when you first brought that up and now
how do you feel well really quickly I
didn't like it at all because I felt
like we should just go with something
that happens on Friday night or Saturday
night where people are having drinks
having fun and just frame it as
entertainment by having it on Sunday
it's like what what does culture
associate Sunday afternoon with going to
church and now we're going to have this
framing of like oh an alternative to
church and people are going to think of
it as some kind of religion or some kind
of cult and I didn't like that at all
but
this event made me realize a couple of
things that number one if we just do the
Friday Saturday night thing it's like
we don't really have the opportunity to
do what isn't being done I think we can
be good I think we can create fun but
people are already doing that
I think by doing this on Sunday and
accepting the challenge that comes with
that framing we have a chance to do
something that isn't being done because
the need for this is based on the fact
that lots of people are rejecting what's
being done and they've been rejecting it
for a long time and so people want to
know what can Community look like
outside of depending on a church that I
don't want to go to so let's build this
community together
sundaysymposium.com where you can get
your free tickets or the paid for
tickets like I said if you can afford it
help us pay for the venue because Ryan
and I lost a lot of money at the first
one and it's okay we're we're trying to
build this community and you can help us
at least break even with that but even
if you can't afford it we're providing
half the tickets for free Sunday
symposium.com let's build something
special together we'll have a special
guest some music some conversation some
q a lot of love a lot of dogma-free
conversation for our added value this
week I got a song for you it's a guy
named Knox I stumbled across him on
Instagram TK and it took me back to the
Audis sort of this indie rock
upbeat Vibe and the song is called
sneakers which is the double entender
because it's about like he said I don't
run around with Sneakers but like also
people who sneak around behind your back
right and it's a song about relationship
boundaries about setting standards
before you get into a relationship you
don't want to be four years in a
relationship
and then you start to set boundaries
then of course it's okay to re-establish
boundaries but the best time to set your
boundaries is up front and then you can
change them together as the relationship
continues and it's also a song about
self-love in a way I'm not willing to
tolerate this kind of behavior in a
relationship enjoy the song This is
sneakers by Knox by the way TK we got a
bunch more surprise questions on the
private podcast this week like will my
relationship fail if I don't love myself
more than my partner how do we avoid
moving too fast in a relationship if
there's a strong Chemistry Between Us
at what point in a new relationship
should you tell your partner you have a
micro penis
[Music]
[Laughter]
and isn't here to answer that one
no we're gonna get serious on that one
actually and it's not really about about
that but we talked to John and Vanessa
about certain expectations we place on
ourselves that make us miserable before
we even start a relationship and make us
afraid of being in a relationship we're
going to talk about that plus a million
more questions for Vanessa John TK and
myself and if you want to hear all that
tell them what to do in Alabama check
out the minimalist private podcast visit
patreon.com the minimalists or click the
link in the description to subscribe and
get your personal links so that our
weekly maximal episodes play in your
favorite podcast app you'll also gain
immediate access to all of our archives
recordings of Live Events weekly home
tours and our private community of
thousands of open-minded minimizers like
you if you have a question or comment
for our podcast give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast the minimalist.com you can
follow the minimalist on Tick Tock
Instagram Facebook and Twitter at the
minimalist to get our podcast show notes
in your inbox sign up for our email list
at theminimalist.com thank you malabama
that's our show for today on behalf of
Ryan Nicodemus TK Coleman Alabama
podcast Sean Jordan no more Professor
Sean social just Danny unknown
post-production Peter Emma The Immigrant
and the rest of our team my name is
Joshua Fields Melbourne they can leave
here today with just one message
love people
and use things
is the opposite never works thanks for
listening
peace
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed or I bet that you'll be fine
without it foreign